auf eu ebene kommt da zumindest der öl
stoppt oder ein ganz klarer fahrplan in
den öl stoppt
das liegt auf europäischer ebene an den
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
ja was sagen sich die sanktionen weil
die sanktionen nur geschlossen werden
können wenn sie einstimmig von allen 27
staaten auf den weg gebracht werden ich
persönlich bin der meinung dass wir
einen sofortigen einen sofortigen kohle
und öl stoppt brauchen mit öl verdient
übrigens putin am meisten weil man sich
die gewinnmargen anschaut und öl wie sie
sich auch relativ einfach auf den
weltmärkten kompensieren mit anderen
lieferketten bei gas haben wir mit der
pipeline problematik sonderproblem aber
bei öl und kohle kohle können wir
schneller aussteigen gehen sofort
aussteigen und das ist die klare
position nicht darf in den übrigen klare
rückmeldung aus der europäischen debatte
geben werden letzte woche im
europäischen parlament von frei
gewählten abgeordneten aus ganz europa
eine abstimmung zu einer resolution das
ist exakt eingesetztes gemacht wird weil
die staaten entscheiden aber es gibt ja
gefühle über die stimmungslage und
selbst im europäischen parlament in der
breiten mehrheit hatten wir über 80
prozent der abgeordneten versorgt haben
jetzt sofort ihr kollege spengler ich
bin dieser in diese debatte herr weber
ihr kollege liberale gefahr hochstadt
der ist ja quasi auf deutschland
losgegangen er hat einen wutanfall
bekommen in dieser parlamentsrede der
hat massiv geschimpft auf deutschland
der hut vor allen dingen gesagt die
sanktionen so stufenweise das ist dieser
auftritt sogar über deutschland auf
deutschland schimpft und erklärt warum
das nicht funktioniert steht den
sanktionen aktuell dass die nämlich dem
diktator in moskau überhaupt nicht
beeindrucken weil das heißt keine
demokratie ist diese stufenweise weitere
eskalation an sang zu uns die hat nichts
gebracht dazu haben wir eine insa
umfrage an diesem wochenende
durchgeführt und haben unsere zuschauer
einmal gefragt glauben sie dass die
sanktionen aktuell greifen dass die den
mann in moskau im kreml aktuell
beeinflussen dass die wirkung entfalten
und die mehrheit der deutschen glauben
wir nicht dass glauben wir aktuell nicht
dass die aktuell bestehenden sanktionen
tatsächlich wirken deswegen noch mal
herr stegner das ist die umfrage dazu
also knapp 70 prozent sagen nein das
kommt bei putin noch gar nicht an das
bringt doch gar nicht sie sind gar nicht
wirksam die eu sanktionen jetzt sagt
manfred weber gerade herr stegner
sofortiger stopp ist mit ihnen zu machen
ist das mit der spd zu machen und mit
dem kanzler zu machen glaube schon dass
das eine möglichkeit ist weil er lieber
ja recht hat dass der gute ihn
hauptsächlich damit geld verdienen das
ist leichter zu substituieren und was
die sanktions wirkung angeht glaube ich
kann man umfragen dazu machen
entscheiden ist es die alliierten
gemeinsamen versucht haben die
schärfsten möglichen sanktionen
verhängen sich bisher jemals gegeben hat
und das über uns zielgerichtet zu tun
anders als früher dass man jetzt nicht
sofort werde so aber nach allem was ich
weiß jedenfalls gibt es da keinen großen
dissens darüber soll im gegenteil das
wird einvernehmlich verabredet kann es
nur von den deutschen und manch einer
der uns öffentlich beschimpft so zu
sagen hat hinter verschlossenen türen
vereinbart genau das mit das ist so das
will ich gar nicht beklagen aber der
kern ist dass wir die dinge immer nur
gemeinsam machen können das passiert
auch mit dem ziel dass putin regime zu
treffen und womöglich stärker zu treffen
als uns selbst